premier cours de Dior pour ce jeune
homme la technique d'intervention
opérationnelle rapprochée n'est pas au
programme de l'école d'ingénieur
commerce mais la leçon devrait être bien
retenue avec la course d'orientation la
marche pas ou le parcours d'obstacles
cette semaine d'intégration et musclée
c'est plutôt physique on n'arrête pas
mais ça nous permet vraiment de de
dépasser nous-mêmes de se dépasser en
groupe d'apprendre à nous connaître on
fait plein d'activités et les journées
sont bien remplies je trouve que pour
l'instant ça se passe bien il y a la
cohésion qui augmente on va dire les
liens il se sert car le but est bien que
les 40 nouveaux étudiants fassent
connaissance et se fassent confiance
pour les cinq années à venir les plus
anciens en atteste on a beaucoup de
travaux de groupe à faire à l'école et
on n'est pas souvent avec nos amis avec
des personnes qu'on apprécie forcément
et donc du coup le fait de se retrouver
là tout le temps ensemble dès le début
ça nous sert beaucoup ici dans un
premier temps à l'armée mais également
dans le civil quand on va devoir faire
nos travaux de groupe et plus tard dans
le monde du travail également
si à l'origine c'est la grande école qui
a démarché le régiment pour cette
immersion les militaires ont très vite
trouvé du sens dans le partage de leur
univers
globalement on attend deux qui
deviennent des cadres c'est pour ça
qu'ils sont rentrés dans une grande
école des cadres ça veut dire des gens
qui auront à exercer des responsabilités
à prendre des décisions et à les assumer
et puis quelque part à avoir aussi
charges d'âme ils auront des subordonnés
ici ils viennent chercher les vertus
qu'on développe en tant que militaire le
courage l'abnégation le goût de l'effort
et du dépassement de soi le sens du
service aux autres etc petit salé aux
lentilles rougail saucisse avec ton
copain allez première ration première
ampoules au pied et premier surnom les
ingénieurs commerces se remémoreront
longtemps cette expérience bien au-delà
des bancs de l'école